falsch und ich bin krank wir sind heute
mal wieder im guten alten browser
unterwegs und zwar möchten wir das spiel
spielen teste dich da geht es darum dass
man sich testet ja wir geben jetzt hier
oben einfach mal konkreter ein und sehen
jetzt schon wie gut kennst kontraste
video ten zu kommen auf der welt alles
passt zu dir wir nehmen einfach mal wie
gut kennst kontraste und jetzt müssen
wir diese fragen beantworten also frage
nummer eins kontrakt hat seinen kanal am
ersten 8 2011 eröffnet als keiner hat
viel vor ich würde sagen ja ich glaub
das war im august also er macht nur
blogs falsche hat über 850.000
abonnenten stand vierte siebte ja ich
bin mir nicht sicher alter er hat drei
kanäle also ich glaub ich habe locker
irgendwie viel youtube-kanäle aber vom
zweiten wisst ihr nichts die anderen mir
gehören sind krank und paddy power
eigentlich glaube ich ich glaube also
man weiß und das ist zwar kann er also
falsch würde ich mal sei er auf qik
aktiv nein als untersteht er liebt
alpakas waren hass geht alltag wie ist
das in frage aber so die wird sagen war
okay villiger war war die falsche wahl
kommen billiger er macht böse commands
was sind böse commands das was muss man
das irgendwie ich sag mal einfach war
oder böse er einlädt komme ich nach
falsch also diese letzte frage
übertrifft wirklich alles was dieses
komplette
chris bis jetzt bieten hatte lutz ist
der beste das ist definitiv war wie
gekonnt packers an die macht das war
mega gut sie haben zehn von zehn
aufgaben richtig beantwortet
aber wir haben hier noch ein zweites
quiz und zwar heißt es ebenfalls wie gut
kennst du von kraft aber es ist von cora
langer kontrakt hat seinen kanal am
ersten august 2011 eröffnet ja das
hatten wir ja gerade schon er war bei
minecraft hero nicht dabei falsch ich
war dabei von softeis mit bürgerlichen
namen lukas er besitzt einen 2 kanal war
er hat ein format mit minecraft war er
gut mittlerweile nicht mehr
beziehungsweise pausiert ich belasse es
bei wahl von kraft das team taten war ok
boss von in vivo 1 ja sie belegten
insgesamt 22 tage das ist eine freche
frage ehrlich gesagt ich würde sagen war
ich glaube zwar nicht dass wir so gut
waren aber ich bin optimistisch von
crafter hat grüne augen
mich ist das total komisch ich würde
sagen war ja komm grüne augen hat
dunkelbraune haare falsch er lässt seine
kleidung von seiner mutter auch freunde
die frage doch nicht sein müssen es ist
aber war okay auswertung was was neun
von zehn nur was soll da ist ich war
voll gut eigentlich oman wieso denn nur
neun von zehn im durchschnitt haben 1542
surfer die das gemacht haben 705
richtige antwort gegeben
wenigstens war ich besser als der
durchschnitt minecraft crafting kurs wie
crafted man was hier erfährst wie gut du
dich mit minecraft auskennst kuchen
crafted man mit drei milchzucker ein ei
ich würde sagen dass oder eher kommen
nehmen wir das sieht ralf tittmann
leinen egal woher soll ich wissen wie
man leider keinen spinnen franz
weinberger keine ahnung redstone
schienen
ist das euer ernst kann ich mal so was
kommen wie man schwert macht oder sowie
kraft
pisten es ist so ein scheiß kremsner wie
crafted man gemälde das gehe ich ja
jetzt wohl hier nicht meine nehme ich
mal braucht
acht stücke ein wolle ja das ist
definitiv richtig letzte frage so noch
eins der schwierigsten wie crafted man
kaninchen raycon degas ich weiß nicht
mal da die muslime dass es das gibt in
minecraft vier von zehn aufgaben richtig
beantwortet was kannst du eigentlich ich
glaub ich werd dem namen minecraft kanal
richtig gerecht okay hier gibt es auch
noch das spiel welcher let's play passt
zu dir und das wurde 37.000 mal
aufgerufen wenn plötzlich contractor
rauskommt dann ist aber echt traurig
kriegs in 56 player drin und zwar sind
dass hardy schaffe den und ich habe
meine lieblings youtube wie stellst du
dir deinen youtuber vor
witzig und nett keine ahnung was machst
du von denen sachen am
wahrscheinlichsten in deiner freizeit
zocken spieler aufregen lombach
tatsächlich spieler auch risiken
wer sitzt denn in seiner freizeit gerne
was geht alter welche augenfarbe hast du
ja grün aber als ob mein lieblings
youtuber anhand meiner augenfarbe über
eine da was ihr altes tut was ist dir in
einer beziehung wichtig ihr charakter
tatsächlich in einer beziehung der
charakter wenn ich kurzfristig was und
einer habe dann ist es aussehen er aber
bei der beziehung definitiv der
charakter in welcher jahreszeit bist du
politiker ist das denkt ein ernst ich
bin im frühling geboren soll nächste
frage wer was isst du am liebsten von
diesen gerichten
ich mag nichts davon pizza definitiv
pizza bist du gespannt auf das resultat
ja komm jetzt mach doch welcher ist der
lieblings über der folgenden als ob ist
das deren ernst du beantwortet die ganze
zeit fragen um herauszufinden wer dein
lieblings youtuber ist und am ende kommt
die frage wer ist dein lieblings
youtuber fucking killing me was ist das
denn konkret da passt zu mir
welche 42 sind sie der perfekte let's
play
ja ich glaube dass sollte man nicht
durch lesen der perfekte live player für
dich ist conny luca von crafter ihr
beide können sich über spiele aufregen
die aber trotzdem spielten auch in der
freizeit hättet ihr spaß jedes profil
hatten vier prozent der 19.000 quiz
teilnehmer 40 prozent sind sie der
perfekte letztlich felix vom da laden
ihr seid schillig und bleibt dabei cool
in der scheidter seid ihr nicht auch
zusammen aber trotzdem liebt ihr euch
okay ich bin zu null prozent der freunde
ich wollte meine hände zusammen schlagen
aber ich hab dabei einfach mein mikrofon
geschlagen dass ich habe mir gerade voll
gegen das kinn gehauen
das war es mit diesem video wenn solche
fehler wie ich mich über eine bewertung
freuen wenn nicht dann geht doch einfach
tschüss